merci monsieur le Président ma question
s'adresse à madame la ministre de la
transition énergétique madame la
ministre alors que la France dispose du
part hydroélectrique le plus important
de l'Union européenne que ce parc
produit 12 % de la production nationale
d'électricité et qu'il est essentiel
pour le mix énergétique sa situation est
aujourd'hui fragilisée par des années
d'indécision les 340 ouvrages exploités
sous le régime de la concession de
service public
font face à l'absence de renouvellement
des concessions échues dont de nombreux
ouvrages dans la vallée de la Truyère et
du Lot en Aveyron la situation du parc
hydroélectrique ne nécessite une action
urgente et déterminée en raison des
conditions de renouvellement des
concessions échues exploité en délai
glissant et du contexte juridique
modifié par la règle d'orientation
européenne
après la privatisation et le
démantèlement d'EDF prévu dans le projet
Hercule sur lequel je vous avais déjà
interrogé ici même il y a deux angles et
qui aura provoqué de nombreuses
oppositions contre lui le gouvernement
est resté dans les spectative en ce sens
la Cour des comptes a adressé une
véritable mise en garde au gouvernement
le 6 février dernier en soulignant la
nécessité de sortir rapidement de cette
situation afin d'éviter que la situation
ne se dégrade plus encore et je cite oui
madame la ministre il est urgent de vous
intéresser à ce problème dernièrement
l'hydroélectricité n'a a été abordé dans
le projet de loi relatif à
l'accélération de la production
d'énergie renouvelable ni dans celui
visant accéléré la construction de
nouveaux réacteurs nucléaires vous
pouvez toujours vous abriter derrière
l'annonce d'un prochain grand texte sur
le sujet mais en attendant l'effet sont
là alors madame la ministre pouvez-vous
pouvez-vous nous dire si vous partagez
le constat sévère de la Cour des comptes
sur l'inaction du gouvernement
pouvez-vous nous dire si vous partagez
la solution consistant à ceux que les
concessions soient fondées sur un
ensemble de considérations économique et
juridique madame la ministre dites-nous
vos difficultés sous le sujet et nous
pourrons vous aider comme la Cour des
comptes vient de le faire je vous
remercie pour vous répondre la parole